test your students not your patience so
what is the idea of this talk in late
2013 I started my PhD with a car and he
came to me and said yeah there's a new
course on applied empirical methods for
Business Administration students and
you're going to be the teaching
assistant and there will be five
take-home assignments and the final exam
and all this for 150 students then I
said well 150 students that's quite a
lot and thinking of having to grade all
this stuff I said yeah okay maybe we can
do better and since we wanted to
innovate this course and use Mathematica
for all the course materials for all the
interactive stuff for all the data
working with data said okay so then it
wouldn't make sense to do a paper and
pencil exam so let's do Mathematica base
exams and try to create this
automatically so and didn't our
adventures of automated testing and
grading started so the basic idea is the
student got a mathematical notebook
their individualized exam file and
within this file they were asked to
solve problems using code and some tools
we provided for them and I imagine there
are 150 students in one classroom and
everyone has a
laptop open so it's very hard to detect
cheating and it's very easy just to copy
some one line of code or some numbers
from your neighbor and so our approach
was we have to prevent cheating not by
supervising and not by what other
people's try video record the students
we have to prevent cheating in a way
that it simply doesn't make sense and
our approach is we use randomization on
the questions and we use
individualization so that means you get
you get a question but every student get
slightly different numbers in this
question so the basic idea the the
concept of the question stays the same
but the solutions are different and with
this methods we managed to make an exam
or the probability that two exams are
the same is less than winning the
lottery so it doesn't make sense to try
to find a pattern of individualization
of randomization in order to cheat so
yeah and that works quite well and
furthermore there's some security and
identification issues I don't want to go
into much detail at the end all the
exams were designed to be available for
automatic grading and of course we also
wanted to give individual feedback and
here is a file of an actual exam from
it's hard to see right
this vacation okay so that's that an
exam file from the first round there's
some true or false questions but the
interesting part comes here so here we
students had to interpret graphs and
tables and all those graphs and tables
were individualized and then we had some
coding questions and this is a really
yeah as applied as it gets in an exam so
you are faced with the problem you were
asked to choose an approach and then
here do some coding all the data already
included in the in the notebook and then
interpret your results so and so that
there was quite successful I would say
so it would take a lot of time and
grading it was very accurate here you
see the reporting
stay is sweating so here you had to
enter your matriculation number I'm
doing this at the moment and then for
each student there was a individual
feedback on the exam and on the
assignments and the final grade as well
and we always have the possibility that
the students can compare to their peers
oh ok so this disappeared now there's
one big problem with this first you have
to deal with a lot of files so you have
to distribute the files to the students
and you have to make sure that you get
some files back that are easily can be
easily read and also yeah the more
dynamic and schedule test and
initialization you build in a
mathematica file the more likely it is
that it crests on on some students
machines when you're in the classroom
with 150 students then it's very likely
that you end up with a hundred
combinations of operating systems and
hardware and you never know what what
happens and so we had some crashes only
a few but yeah so what we're doing now
we're still using the mathematical files
but now we kind of outsourced the coding
so here you see an assignment from this
year and then you click on the button
and then you get the data set in the
separate notebook you can do the
calculations there and then here select
some answers and Here write some some
text answers but so this this makes the
files much more robust yeah and the
reporting this is an an issue with data
security so we cannot give out files
that contain all the informations for
all the students even though we can kind
of hide them that they have to enter
their matriculation numbers but when
they are clever enough they can read out
the source code of the notebook and then
they would find all the results from all
the students so what we are doing now is
we generate PDF reports and we are
individualizing them a little bit then
we also have this comparison detailed
feedback and overall comparison so yeah
that works but again there's a lot of
files a lot of emails we are using so
yeah we already see huge improvement of
efficiency and accuracy but there is
potential to to make it better and to go
one step further and this is what we are
doing now we want to take all this to
the cloud good afternoon everyone I'm
Carlos a when i took a when i started
working at the institute with the
carlaandmike mike had already done all
this improvement offline but um
sorry for that mmm then we we realize
that distributing files a problem
managing all those everything was a
complete disaster we just couldn't be
sure that is the the students will
actually do what we want them to do of
course there is always a trade of you
have to constrain them on what you want
them the to answer but there is also a
trade-off of what the actual time that
you save we said okay what's a stander
in absolutely every platform a web
browser let's go into the web and but
let's keep the cool features that we
have in Mathematica to develop this
interactive tools and is still posting
locally about the same time Mathematica
10.0 came out we had these cloud objects
and in that him I'm really sorry about
this no we had so many problems with the
hotel connection that I was doing it
offline let's do it online
okay so sorry about that let me just go
back for a second we said okay we keep
the individualized questions that's not
big enough I think right so after
several weeks of thinking how are we
going to individualize questions if we
if you have one parameter that it's
dependent of some other in the question
and then in the sub question and then in
there in the answer okay that came hell
after two or three weeks we realize okay
we set the parameters here and we give
them names then we give the minimum
value the maximum value and the steps on
which they can be randomized the number
of accuracy of decimal points nothing
that is a something from the other world
and now let's say that you have apples
that says from 1 to 20 a random number
and then it says Apple next to it and
just because we want to keep it
correctly in English we just add an S or
not depending if it's one or more than
one then the question says i will give
you 10 * new apples of course this is a
silly syl example that you can get the
idea then these new apples would be
randomized from two to five how many do
you have now then you actually calculate
the answer the answer of course it's the
same for every question you just have
these parameters and then when they are
randomized the question they add sorry
the answer is of course given then you
just for display purposes you say the
correct answer is blah blah blah you
could say actually yeah this is quite a
straightforward don't need to reply that
whatever you wonder so we made this
random questions the parameter a from
two to five we have different kinds of
answer types radio button bar slider
input field of course all of every kind
of question every kind of let's say
answer either you want to give you this
multiple choice over it slider or your
input field needs a lot of thought and
that's what we are thinking at the
moment some other old question at the
end this in our pipeline as I said we
had troubles with the internet connect
you parse it it's get it gets pushed
Mathematica retrieves from our database
the number of students that there are it
randomizes every question according to
the student unto the lecture moreover if
you want to retrieve what every student
god it's still possible we thought about
like a week of how to do this possible
randomized but it's still retrievable to
check if a student got actually a very
difficult question if it was worth it
would think it won't be an issue but
just in case is to the students need to
have a we need to have always aside on
what the students are doing so this is
tested let me show you where it actually
deployed so this is our this is our
online platform as you can see
everything individualized etc then we
are here to the exams and that do today
ok we go on take exam you see here the
questions are deployed as cloud objects
embedded us iframes lots of technical
details boring the thing is that here
let's say that you have 6 apple so
that's 36 if I went to elementary school
correctly then we submit this is saved
in a in another cloud object and then we
retrieved and with the functions that
you so know that is so somewhere yeah
right we compared with this one and we
actually grade with those that means
that on the website the student will
never be able to see the answer only we
know that let's keep answer this one 60
cc's was quatrain to her and any guesses
of how old I am
20 I have a beard you know okay let's
say 20 that's it so of course this would
take at least three minutes for a human
to grade those are trained minutes that
we don't have we have lots to do believe
me lots to do we just don't want to do
that but we have already solved that so
we go to the results it's already solved
and Tim here here it is a report is not
as elegant as the one that Mike made for
last year but we are getting to it
sixty-seven percent because we got two
out of three correct first question
answer 36 expected answer we retrieve
that from the cloud object saved and
then the second question a your answer
expected 20 and 20 there's another part
that should be here that I am yeah I
didn't include because there are no
other students is this comparison the
chart that Mike had at the moment it and
the only student taking this one that
wind won't show so this is how we expect
with the presentation this is how we
expect to get things faster oops
takeaways as you saw the day I frames
they look good but they could look
better how can we do that we have tried
the open possibilities of the of the
world from programming cloud I think
that they are not enough you saw that I
had to scroll within the iframes we
don't want that we just want the student
to feel comfortable when doing an exam
not caring about what's it submitted was
it not etc high potential for scaling
this worked for one student it works for
a thousand no need to hire an army of
assistance to grade an opportunity to
get more insights and user behavior do
you know how much time each of your
students takes in every question you can
probably make a guess the most difficult
question might take them fifty percent
of the time during the exam do you
actually get the statistics on that no
if the exam is online you can check
where the student spent all his time a
moreover we can give immediate feedback
to the student like okay you've means
you have spent 15 minutes in these
questions I all your classmates finished
it in three so you're doing something
wrong repeat the thing it again finally
next steps and of course as I said this
insight for life grading and suggestions
of course in we are also thinking that
at the lecture might have an iPad what
supervising the exam and sing oh my god
these guys doing terribly let's go and
talk to him live right there without
needing to see one of every screen of
the hundred and fifty students taking
that exam a add more question formats
and intelligent testing as I suggested
we need to think every time that you
want to randomize something it's not
just as easy as randomizing the
parameters you need to think how can
they answer what are they what do what
they will think and how we can grade
that especially improve user interface
performance and cloud object appearance
as I said once that we could embed those
cool graphics those cool tools those
answers and the the student can just go
through the website as if he were on
facebook they have no need to worry that
oh my god this is a an exam I don't know
how to do those they feel comfortable
they can focus on solving test with the
tools that we can provide them